long ago in the wintry North an army of
demons emerged from beneath the icy
ground and spread darkness and despair
across the land arride their monstrous
spiders flanked by Giants they waked
havoc on the innocent slaughtering
thousands all hope was lost until the
Fearless Warriors of the first Night's
Watch drove them back into the wintry
mountains and built a magic wall to keep
them from ever invading
again these stalwart Brothers in Black
continue to protect us even to this day
from the evils that lurk in the
shadows an absurd lie a fairy tale spun
by many a wet nurse in the north to be
sure a giant wall does exist the Triumph
of engineering perhaps but not of
magic as for the knight's watch there
may have been a time centuries ago when
there was Prestige and honor in the
miserable monastic life of a black
brother but now the wall has become a
glorified penal colony full of outcasts
criminals and assorted n wells for free
you can now listen to the entire Audi
book Fire and Blood On which house of
the Dragon is based and which covers the
entire targaryan history including
current and future events of House of
the Dragon for free with a not trial
using our Link in the
description unlike our Southern Rivals
the Stark Kings of winter didn't Forge
the north into one Kingdom for Glory or
gold there is little of either here but
to survive alone in West Ross the north
remembered when worse than dragons lay
waste to
armies thousands of years ago the sun
set on the Realms of men and the long
night began a new race emerged from the
ice and snow the white walkers they they
demanded no Crown offered no terms
spared no life and the dead marched with
them with Humanity facing extinction a
stark sought out the children of the
forest the most ancient beings in westos
and convinced them to Ally with the men
they once fought together the two races
pushed the Walkers back into the land of
always winter and sealed it off from the
Seven Kingdoms with the wall 300 mil of
ice stone and Earth rising nearly 7 100
ft tall to guard it they established the
knight's watch A brotherhood sworn to
defend the living from the dead whose
vows AR raise both titles and
crimes after the long night the north
tried to forget it belonged to a
continent perhaps through Pride perhaps
through sheer ignorance you never can
tell within
North swords in the
darkness hi the black Brothers of the
knights watch are that at least when he
lies down at night he can't have nobody
to warm his Frozen
bed well not unless the crows like to
Nest together do you think he remembers
the stories they told him
then about when the white walkers woke
in the land of always winter and how the
wall and the Night's Watch were raised
to stop them the next
time I never mind trapping us on the
other side we free flock have our
stories
too about how one of you your king crows
found something cold in the woods with
bright blue
eyes how he brought her home through
your wall and declared himself Knight's
King 13 years he and his Queen ruled
over his brothers making sacrifices as
black as their clocks lucky for you
Southerners the free folk rallied to a
King Beyond the Wall as we will when
need be and marched on the ancient
castle he taken for his his own the
night fought with the help of the Starks
we killed the demon and cleansed your
precious watch and then they thanked us
and kicked us back across the wall as
you always have night gathers and now my
watch
begins it shall not end until my death I
shall take no wife hold no lands father
no children I shall wear no crowns and
win no
glory I shall live and die my
post I am the sword in the
darkness I Am The Watcher on the
walls I am the shield that guards the
Realms of
men I pledge my life and honor to the
knight's watch for this night and all
the nights to
come Legend tells of a winter that
lasted a
generation and of a vast and terrible
darkness that fell across the
land it came to be known as the long
night in the midst of this
Darkness the white walkers emerged from
the Far
North with their armies of the Dead they
waged war against the living laying
waste to Villages and hold fasts
leaving Terror and destruction in the
wake after years of brutal conflict and
unbearable loss an alliance of the first
men and the children of the forest
managed to drive the Walkers and their
minions back into the frigid Northern
wastelands from whence they
came to prevent another
Invasion the first men erected the
wall a massive fortification 700 ft in
height stretching from the frostfang
mountains in the West to the Bay of
seals in the East it was a Structure
unlike any ever built indeed some
maintain it could only have been
completed with the aid of Giants or
using the powerful magic of the ancient
children of the
forest men were required to guard and
maintain it and thus the knight's watch
was born
a sworn Brotherhood tasked was defending
the Realms of men against the dark
Forces that lay Beyond upon taking his
vows a brother of the knight's watch
serves for life it is a life of hardship
and great sacrifice so the oath must not
be taken
lightly the punishment for
desertion is
death joining the knight's watch or
taking the black is a singular honor for
any
northerner for it was in the north some
8,000 years ago that the first man drove
back the white walkers erected the wall
and established the sworn Brotherhood
that would guard the realm and its
people from the dangers
Beyond regrettably the knight's watch no
longer commands the widespread respect
and admiration it once
did while house Stark and other houses
in the northern regions continue to
recognize its vital importance to the
safety and stability of the realm this
view is not shared by the powerful
houses of the Southern kingdoms or their
subjects most regard the watch as a
misguided obsolete order made up of
useless
outcasts admittedly the current Night's
Watch is a shadow of its former glory
the maesters don't believe in Prophecy
with good reason the children of the
forest supposedly could see into the
future yet were surprised by the first
men who nearly ended their race and the
long night which nearly ended us all
some maesters posit that the children's
magical site was invented long after
they vanished from westos by singers
hoping to Thrill peasant girls not that
most MERS have much experience in what
does or doesn't do
that war did not come to wus with men in
the dawn of days the children of the
forest fought the Giants but neither
race sought to destroy the or they claim
to the continent they couldn't the
children hunted and fought with dragon
glass arrows and Spears and the Giants
had only the branches that pulled from
trees nor could both races fill more
than one of the Seven Kingdoms of
today then the southern deserts coughed
up a new race the first men who had
crossed the narrow sea over the arm of
Dorne the first men had never seen seen
in wewood but the children had never
seen bronze the dragon glass arrows
glanced off the first men's Shields and
their armor of woven box split beneath
the first men's swords as the war raged
the children resorted to the one
advantage they had the magic of their
old gods their green seers and listed
direwolves and snow bears cave lions and
Eagles mammoths and serpents in return
the first men cut down and burnt every
wewood they could find fearing that the
children could spy on them through the
faces in the
trees the children became desperate
their green Sears called down the hammer
of waters to break the arm of dawn
destroying the bridge that men crossed
into wos and to flood to the neck to
contain men to the South but the first
men would not be stopped fearing
Extinction the children combined their
powers for one last spell that would
save their people and their land from
the Invaders by themselves the children
were too few to resist the
onslaught but if they could turn men's
numbers against
them after hundred hundreds of years in
Untold death and destruction the wisest
heads of the children and the first men
finally prevailed the children couldn't
win this war and the first men didn't
want to win fearing the cost of Victory
Heroes and rulers on both sides met upon
an aisle in the God's eye to form the
PCT the children gave up all the lands
of westos save for the Deep forests and
the first men swore that they would no
longer cut down the were
Woods thus end Ed the dawn age and began
the age of
Heroes yet after the dawn must come the
night the great evil that the children
Unleashed in the war returned centuries
later and only in Alliance between the
children and Men defeated
it